Okay, so now that we know how to actually manage our landscapes, I think it's time we
take a look at all the ways in which we can actually create landscapes inside of Unreal
Engine.
So, there's a few ways of doing it.
Perhaps the easiest way to actually go ahead about doing this is just using the open world
template.
So, this is an open world template that's going to come with a 2km by 2km landscape
that already has a landscape material setup and all the setups that you'd actually need
if you wanted to create an open world type game.
So, it comes with a world partition, one file per actor, data layers, hierarchical levels
of details.
It's actually a really, really handy template.
So, if you wanted to create a landscape that you can start editing from there in this way,
all you have to do is make a new level and make sure you choose the open world template
here.
And there you go.
You've got a really nice landscape that's already set up for a lot of features and you're
good to go.
You can just go ahead and edit this.
That's one way that you can do it.
Now, the other way that you can do it is by just having a basic world.
And the only reason I'm choosing basic is because we've got a bit of lighting so we
can see what we're doing.
But essentially, you can create a landscape the way we've been creating it.
So, if we go to create new, I'm going to untick edit layers there because that's something
I'm going to cover in a second.
But you could just set up, look at the chart, figure it out, figure out what landscape size
you want, press create.
And there we go.
We've got a landscape.
I can go ahead and start sculpting on this and edit it.
Now, one thing that I did want to cover about landscapes that we haven't covered up until
now is that tick box that I just had to untick there, which is the edit layers.
So if we have enable edit layers, when I create this, we get this really handy feature here
called edit layers, which essentially allows me to store the data that I painted inside
of one of the landscapes into a layer, which means I can slowly use this alpha value to
change the way in which my landscape edits in affects the actual landscape.
To create a new layer, all I have to do is right click create.
And now as long as I've got that layer selected, I'll be storing in that layer the information
that I'm painting now.
And again, all I can do, all I need to do is to click and drag this alpha value.
I can go ahead and edit the intensity or the effect that that layer has on the landscape
itself.
This is a really, really useful tool that I actually really can't live without now.
So I recommend that you actually set it up when you do your own landscape.
Now the last way that we can create a landscape is to just import a height map that we've
generated in something like World Machine or Zebra or Houdini, any real software and
any other DCCE application where you can actually generate a terrain height map image.
You could use the import into Unreal and generate that landscape from it.
So how do we go about doing that?
Well, let's go ahead and delete this landscape once again.
And let's go ahead back to our landscape tool.
And we're going to say import from file.
Now I already have a file set up here, but I'd encourage you to just go into Photoshop
and just paint a few lines in black and white and make sure that you export this as a 16
bit depth image, okay, which you could save as a PNG.
In our case, we've already got one ready.
And remember that the size of this have to be relating to the chart that we mentioned
earlier.
So in our case, it's going to be 1009 by 1009.
So we've got the right resolution.
I've got a scale value here of 150 that I edited already.
And I'm just going to move the landscape up a little bit and let's go ahead and import.
And once we press import, you can see when we generate it from DCC package like this,
we really get a nice level of detail that might be much harder for us to manually paint
inside of Unreal.
So if you want something that's artistic like this, this is a really good tool.
And the beauty of this is that you can still edit it.
So if you wanted to flatten a certain section of this, you could go ahead and use the flatten
tool and flatten it out.
But yeah, put your little houses there if you need to.
Essentially, these are all the ways that we can create a landscape.
And as I say, it's a really versatile system.
I hope this has been useful for you.
The overall things that we've covered are just a few technical details and real world
scenarios in which we can actually create landscape.
We took a look at the managing tools or the manage tab for landscapes and how we can manage
things like LOD in per component and how we can use spline.
We also actually adjust the terrain of the landscape itself, how we can add or delete
components.
And then lastly, we went over different creation techniques for landscapes.
We've only really scratched the surface of what we can do in landscape.
So in the next few courses, we'll be doing stuff that's a lot more detailed and take
a look at things like landscape materials and other fun stuff to do with this amazing
tool, the landscape tool itself.
I hope you enjoyed this and I'll see you next time.